[Music]
hello good evening sky news understands
that a scottish parliamentary committee
has concluded that first minister nicola
sturgeon did
mislead parliament hollyrood's
harassment committee has reached the
conclusion by a majority vote ahead of
the publication of its final report
it will significantly increase pressure
on ms sturgeon
to step down but in the last hour a
spokesperson for the first minister
issued
this statement the first minister told
the truth
to the committee in eight hours of
evidence and stands
by that evidence it is clear from past
public statements that opposition
members
of this committee had prejudiced
prejudiced the first minister at the
outset
of the inquiry and before hearing a word
of her evidence
so this partisan and selective briefing
before the committee has actually
published its final report
is hardly surprising well let's head to
hollywood join our scotland
correspondent james matthews so
james msps on this committee voting
five to four that she did give an
inaccurate account about that now
infamous meeting yeah
i mean that scottish government uh
statement speaking about a partisan
and selective briefing i'm bound to say
they've selected the most salient point
in all of this for many and that is the
question of whether or not nicola
sturgeon
misled the scottish parliament um now
the the background is a government
investigation into alex salmon
and a meeting between salmond and
sturgeon at her house on the 2nd of
april 2018.
alex almond went to that meeting with
his legal advisor they both said
nicolas sturgeon offered to intervene in
this government investigation
she categorically denied that and this
committee they focused on
her written submission and she said i
made clear to him that i had no role in
the process
and would not seek to intervene in it i
took no action as a result of this
meeting so
she says i had a meeting i absolutely
did not seek to intervene
the committee take a different view they
think and
that doesn't square with corroborating
evidence effectively by two different
individuals one of whom
said that he heard nicolas sturgeon say
if it comes to it i will
intervene so they have concluded that
scotland's first minister
has misled that committee and in doing
so has misled parliament
crucially perhaps jonathan they don't
use the word knowingly they don't say
that she
knowingly misled the parliament now that
word knowingly
is important because in terms of
preaching the ministerial code
that's the ground for any breach to
knowingly mislead
the parliament and if there is a breach
of the ministerial court by minister
they are expected
to resign let me read you what this
committee has
voted on by a majority in terms of
finding that nicola sturgeon has misled
parliament
it says the committee notes there is a
fundamental contradiction in the
evidence
in relation to whether at the meeting on
the second of april 2018
the first minister did or did not agree
to intervene
taking account of the competing versions
of the event
the committee believes that she did in
fact leave alex almond with the
impression
that she would if necessary intervene
this is corroborated by duncan hamilton
who was also at the meeting
her written evidence is therefore an
inaccurate account
of what happened and she has misled the
committee on this matter
this is a potential breach they say of
the
ministerial court under the terms of
section 1.3
c remember nicola surgeon's written
statement very
certain that she did not seek to
intervene have a listen to
what she said in oral evidence when she
was asked about that
from the minute i saw the letter i knew
that it would not be appropriate for me
to intervene i
probably was trying to you know soften
that
for him maybe from his accounts i
softened that
too much i was also thinking about you
know in
in real time um
you know is there anything i have to do
do i have to report this to anybody
so all of that was going through my head
um as we were having
this discussion and but i did not
intervene
because for the reasons i set out very
vehemently to
to margaret mitchell i don't think that
would have been appropriate for
for me to do and james plenty of
reaction
coming in already in the last few
minutes the leader of the scottish
conservatives
has repeated his calls for nicola
sturgeon to resign
he's tweeted the committee will publish
its findings in the coming days
and we will wait for that report but we
have already detailed
that nicholas sturgeon lied to the
scottish parliament and for that
she must resign all we're waiting for
is uh confirmation uh what do you make
of that
yeah that's not why it's not surprising
from douglas ross i think that will be
echoed across the opposition
benches i think the way it will play out
jonathan is
uh well actually i think we've got a
taste of it from that scottish
government
spokesperson they will try to rubbish
this committee and rubbish the findings
of this committee they may have a job
i'll say because
you know we're reporting at the moment
one finding on the fact that they think
nicholas sergeant misled parliament
there are there's much there's a lot in
this report
and stay tuned for more in terms of what
they think
about scotland's first minister and her
performance
throughout this matter not just on that
specific meeting and the specific
instance
they think of her misleading parliament
there's other stuff there's other stuff
about
um the history this is a woman who uh
worked right next to alex hammond for
many years described
him as her inspiration and mentor expect
to hear more about
the history knowledge or not
of inappropriate behavior we heard some
of that around
the office of the former first minister
inappropriate behavior who knew what
and when so there's more there's more to
come there will be more on the full
report
when it's published next tuesday at 8
a.m in the morning don't forget it's
remit was to look at what went wrong in
that government
investigation so the good that will come
of this will clearly be to sort out the
weaknesses in that particular
government harassment policy but the
fallout
politically clearly focuses on nicola
sturgeon now
in hollywood thank you very much and